في هذه
الصور في الرياض هذه صور مباشره لوصول
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن الى
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض في مستهل جوله له
في
المنطقه بدر الربيعان وراس الجزيره معنا
من الرياض ماذا في هذه الزياره لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكي بدر
نعم عثمان كما نشاهد وصول وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي الى الرياض من المقرر ان يلتقي
وزير الخارجيه السعويه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان وبعدها ولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان
لقاءات تبحث عدد من الملفات ذات
العلاقه والازمات القائمه حاليه نتحدث عن
الملف الرئيسي في هذه الزياره وملف غزه
وما يجري هناك السعوديه كانت شددت على ان
منع الصعيد ياتي من خلال وقف اطلاق النار
في غزه وايجاد مسار للتهدئه عبر تفاعل
حقيقي في المنطقه وايضا دعت لافساح المجال
لمسار السلام في هذه المرحله ثلاثه اركان
في التعاطي مع هذه الازمه تبحث السعوديه
في كل لقاءاتها الثنائيه سواء مع مع القوى
الدوليه وايضا مع ذات المنظمات ذات
التاثير العالمي ايضا ايقاف التصعيد في
البحر مرا احد الملفات الهامه التي
سيبحثها بلينكن هنا في الرياض تاثير على
مسارات السلام في اليمن نعلم ان السعوديه
بحثت في خلال المرحله الحاليه اي تبحث عن
مسارات حقيقيه ل خارج الخروج هذه الازمه
على الصعيد السياسي والعسكري والانساني
ايضا والسعوديه دعت الى ضبط النفس منذ اول
ايام القصف الامريكي على اليمن في هذه
المرحله